quem é que não gosta de um convite de
aniversário de formatura de casamento eu
particularmente adoro convites convite
faz ser lembrado ele te fase pra algum
lugar novo conhecer pessoas diferentes
rever amigos e familiares em convite ele
te faz hoje claro dependendo da sua
resposta
certo dia eu recebi um morador e
ex-líder comunitário da comunidade
relatores
ele me fez um convite na hora pensei que
era pra algum casamento algum adversário
mas não era um convite diferente
ele falou e perguntou para o sermão
jovem imobilizadora na comunidade
não hora eu olhei para ele e falei não
sei realmente o que eu posso o que eu
posso fazer o que eu posso oferecer
mas eu aceitei eu tinha apenas 16 anos
eu estava pensando no meu futuro aquela
fase de o que cursar a faculdade
eu pensava em engenharia ambiental
medicina veterinária e jornalismo
optei por jornalismo porque eu pensei
que utilizando as ferramentas da
comunicação e da comunicação é poderia
eu poderia dar voz para a comunidade os
moradores da vila torres colocar para
toda a sociedade a importância que a
vila torres tem pra curitiba a vila das
torres a uma comunidade central de
curitiba
rodeado por grandes empresas e
principais avenidas
mas mesmo com a sua boa localização o
tráfico ea violência sim são um grande
problema lá dentro
aquele convite me fez olhar para a
comunidade diferente não só como a
moradora
mas também como uma como a pessoa que
poderia sim fazer a diferença
mudar aquela realidade então eu comecei
a analisar todo o cenário primeiro
analisei o meu a minha realidade o que
eu via minha mãe meu pai trabalhando
incansavelmente no comércio dentro da
comunidade proporcionando pra mim meu
irmão uma boa qualidade de vida e saúde
e educação e depois eu olhei o lado
externo lado externo todas as crianças
da comunidade cheia de saúde energia
brincando correndo pela rua aproveitando
um pouco de liberdade que elas tinham
mas à mercê de toda
a violência e foi eu percebi que ela
recebeu muitos convites também só
aqueles convites não eram e não
contribuíram para o crescimento delas
junto com o grupo de voluntários que
comecei a fazer parte
nós começamos a pensar nossa primeira
ação dentro da vila
pensamos que a comunidade tinha que se
conhecer melhor e os moradores também se
conhecer
foi aí que nós pensamos nossa primeira
ação foi o dia da cultura de lá torres o
dia da cultura foi o momento em que
convidamos todos os moradores para
apresentar o seu talento em um palco
qual fosse é que encantasse dançar se
contar uma piada tocar algum instrumento
não importava importava o momento de
eles participarem se apresentar e
mostrar todo seu potencial
sei que eu percebi que a comunidade
tinha um grande potencial
tinha pessoas de fibra e que queriam
mudança elas queriam ver a mudança e
elas queriam fazer isso mas elas
precisavam de uma ajuda então a gente
viu nossa responsabilidade e começamos a
analisar o cenário agora toda a
comunidade
o que nós vimos nós percebemos que a
comunidade era rica não só de pessoas
mas por um produto que entrava todos os
dias pelas ruas da comunidade eram os
livros que os catadores de papel os
carrinheiros encontravam por toda a
cidade de curitiba e vendiam os
depósitos de reciclagem
a gente pensou esses livros podem ter um
destino melhor fake nós começamos uma
campanha uma mobilização com os
moradores com os carrinheiros e com os
amigos para jantar e arrecadar livros e
montar a biblioteca comunitária da vila
torres é e a partir disso a gente
começou a ter muitas pessoas colaborando
contribuindo 20 conseguiu arrecadar
muitos livros mas ainda há gente não
tinha espaço
tínhamos os livros no espaço eu pensei
que eu fiquei vendo aquela realidade
falei isso não pode continuar
nós estamos livres alguma coisa tem que
ser feita então eu peguei alguns livros
e caminhei da minha casa até a pracinha
da comunidade e no trajeto cada criança
que eu via na rua eu convidava
comigo na pracinha eu falava alto ainda
na pracinha quero eu vou ler levando
alguns livros vamos ali comigo eu me
surpreende que não precisa muitos
argumentos nem mostrou ótimo uma
tecnologia algo assim
foi muito interessante elas foram se
interessando foram participando eu só
pegar os livros colocava nos banquinhos
nas mesas espalhadas deixar velas viajar
naquele mundo acredita em manusear um
livro naquele momento para ela era algo
mágico algo diferente é um mundo
diferente
foi aí que eu comecei a perceber o
potencial que cada uma delas tinha o
valor a curiosidade delas e eu falei pra
mim mesmo é que eu podia oferecer mais
muito mais
todo mundo podia levar para o grupo de
voluntários
essa idéia de proporcionar algo melhor
para elas algo mais
sei que nós montamos com estímulos monk
que a organização de desenvolvimento do
potencial humano
hoje nós vamos ações contínuas dentro
dentro da do nosso espaço proporcionando
para elas uma melhor qualidade de vida
incentivando elas a sobre os princípios
os princípios humanos nas relações
humanas e principalmente a importância
da família e também de crescer sem medo
de crescer acreditando no potencial
delas
eu tinha só 16 anos não tinha recurso
material não tinha recurso financeiro
não tinha diploma mas eu recebi o
convite
a partir dele eu analisei um cenário e
comecei agir tomar algumas atitudes
alguns dias atrás eu tive que substituir
o educador unaí uma atividade atividade
do dia era definir e trabalhar com uma
palavra a palavra já estava lá no quadro
era amizade
só que tem uma palavra que eu gosto
muito e eu acabei apagando aquela
actividade aquela palavra
a educadora não gostou muito mas eu
falei que eu gostava muito então eu
queria colocar aqui aquilo pra elas eu
queria proporcionar algo pra elas que
ama identi.ca identificável
então eu
vi a palavra determinação é eu perguntei
pra ela pra vocês o que a determinação o
que te faz ser determinado tem sete
crianças que estavam ali comigo uma é
respondeu que determinação era terminar
uma ação e outra respondeu que
determinação era determinar ao e as
outras cinco não que nunca nem chutar
claro que nunca ouvir aquela palavra mas
aí eu falei então tá
achei muito legal que as outras duas
tinham falado
vamos tentar que juntos vamos escrever
uma frase com essas duas definições
aí ficou assim determinação é terminar
algo para sua vida é correr atrás das
possibilidades para conquistar tal
objetivo e terminar com uma ação é a
chegada a consequência de sua força de
vontade e perseverança para alcançar
aquilo que foi determinado por você e
todos nós e principalmente as crianças
devem ser motivados e inspirados e
provocados
elas sabem o que elas querem pra vida
delas e nós só estamos proporcionando
momentos e experiências
mas cabe a cada uma delas decidir o
caminho a seguir
a educação é o princípio que desenvolve
o potencial humano é nossa vida em
nossas atitudes nossas experiências é e
às vezes a gente precisa só de uma
oportunidade como o convite de um amigo
e eu faço um convite pra vocês busquem
sempre desenvolver o seu individual e
contribuam com a sua comunidade
por que todo resultado todo o trabalho
ele só ele tem ele só termina através da
sua vontade e da sua determinação
obrigada